look at this it's like jello hey guys
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
now I know we all have canned soup in
our pantries whether we want to admit it
or not it's probably been sitting there
for at least the past six months but I
have a way that you can use that canned
soup and beef it up so it's actually a
meal that satisfies so I'm gonna add
tons of lean protein fiber rich veggies
and whole grains to my soups to make
them into a meal you can actually look
forward to eating so let's get to it
okay guys so first we're gonna make my
tomato bean chili so this starts with a
can of condensed of tomato soup and we
all have tomato soup on hand it's one of
my childhood favorites awesome with
grilled cheese but there's not a whole
lot going on right you don't feel very
full after that so I'm gonna add a
little bit of water just to loosen it up
now we've got a can of diced tomatoes to
add a little bit more texture some
beautiful fresh zucchini bell pepper
some frozen corn a big can of black
beans so I've got some spicy chili
pepper some garlic powder and some cumin
and we're just going to let that simmer
till all the flavors marry we've got a
really nice hearty stew
[Music]
okay so next we're gonna make my sausage
kale and squash soup so starts with some
butternut squash soup trash one of my
babes I'm gonna add in some frozen
butternut squash because I like to get a
little bit of textural contrast with
this soup next I've got some shredded
kale leaves some cooked turkey sausage
and get the kind that's got a little bit
of spice added to it because I like the
flavor contrast then I've got a
combination of wild and brown rice this
is already cooked it's great if you've
got leftovers in your fridge so you can
just basically dump it all into the pot
so just gonna give this a quick little
stir let all the flavors come together
and warm through and we're gonna make a
little garnish for it okay so I just put
the soup to the side I'm just gonna let
it simmer and all come together while I
heat up and toast some pepitas so just a
little bit of olive oil in the pan
and we've got some beautiful pumpkin
seeds or pepitas as they're often called
and I'm also gonna add in some fresh
sage this is one of my favorite favorite
herbs
[Music]
and finally my mushroom broccoli soup so
this starts with this jiggly concoction
cream of mushroom soup the soup that
nobody really understands why it exists
but here it is alas finding its way into
recipes and housewives homes everywhere
I promise I will make this edible so
next we're gonna add in some evaporated
milk and I like this because it's really
so much creamier but at the same time
really really light and low-fat okay so
next I'm gonna add in some fresh chopped
broccoli and I like to chop it nice and
fine so that way it cooks really really
quickly in the soup okay now I'm gonna
add in a can of white beans some cooked
quinoa and I'm just gonna stir this all
together until it turns into a nice
creamy thick luxurious student okay so
while this is bubbling away and the
broccoli is just softening up and
getting tender I'm going to pop a couple
little whole-grain crostinis under the
broiler with a little bit of sharp
cheddar on top
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed these fun little canned
soup hacks if you did be sure to give
this video the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of your favorite
pantry staples
I totally will breathe some new life
into them and give them a little
makeover also don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]